hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
talk about some of the news related to
Game of Thrones Season eight after the
release of the first trailer there's
been a stream of new information to
build the height for the upcoming season
and I started out focusing on the
interview with the actor who plays the
night key this led me to think about the
bigger picture so we'll get into that as
well there are no real spoilers here
just my thoughts based on what we know
from the show and from reading the books
and following along with all the
theories that are out there about how
the game of thrones TV series will end
so let's jump into it in my last couple
of videos I talked about the trailer
what they're giving us in the press
about the epic Battle of Winterfell and
what I thought the show would have to do
to give us a good and memorable ending
they are in fact being liberal with
details about this battle telling us all
about what went into shooting it when it
will happen in the season and just
generally hyping it to be the big
centerpiece of season 8 I thought this
was suspicious at first and then when I
saw the episode run times it got even
more interesting we know there are
roughly seven hours in season eight the
first three episodes are shorter was
episode three being 60 minutes we know
the battle for Winterfell will happen in
this episode we also know that it will
be the longest continuous battle in
cinematic history
lastly more than 40 minutes if it ends
in episode 3 that means we have four
more hours of story after the battle
concludes there are a lot of
possibilities that I won't get into here
but this is something to keep in mind
because that sure looks like there's a
whole lot of story to tell after what
happens in Winterfell goes down in the
interview with the night king actor he
drops a few interesting pieces of
information the first is that the night
king has a specific target and we will
find out who that is I believe this is
brand and this video was originally just
going to be about the reasons I think
that is the case for me in the way I
think about the story his first
statement would have been enough for me
to say he's after bran
but a second statement makes that even
clearer in my opinion when asked what
the night king wants he said somebody
made him the night king nobody knows who
he was before a soldier or part of
nobility
he never wanted to be the night
I think he wants revenge everybody in
the story has two sides a bad side and a
good side the night king only has one
side a bad side so we know the children
of the forest made him the night King as
much as we can know anything in the
story because bran watched that happen
through the weirwoods
in that scene we can see that he's tied
up and appears to be having this done to
him against his will the Lord tells us
that the children were doing this
because they were losing a war with the
first men they created what we now refer
to as the White Walkers to give them an
advantage in this conflict that means
that the White Walkers were created to
defeat humanity and we know they did
this because the first man were moving
into their forest and more importantly
cutting down the weirwood trees from
what we know though this didn't work out
as planned and eventually their creation
led Westeros into the long night we will
get to learn a lot more about this when
the prequel series comes out but
ultimately the children in the first men
had to join together in order to beat
back this invention which threatened to
destroy everyone now of course they are
back the White Walkers that is and they
have been moving south for the first
time in a long time in last season they
finally made it through the wall and now
we know that Humanity is going to have
to face them at Winterfell as far as the
story goes it's important to remember
why they were created and what they do
they kill humans they also kill
everything else which wasn't exactly
what the children had in mind
but the fact that the actor told us he
wants revenge and has the target doesn't
change that the reason why I think he's
after bran and why there aren't even any
other likely candidates is based on a
few things first despite being very
effective at killing people and adding
them to their army of the Dead I think
the show has made it clear that they
aren't mindless in this endeavor there
are several examples where we see what
looks like strategic moves from the
night king despite how we feel about the
events of the trip beyond the wall to
capture the white and season seven it
seems plainly obvious that the plan was
for the night came to capture a dragon
that he could use to get through the
wall he devised the plan and follow
through with it
which to me makes him a much greater
threat not to go on and on about this
episode
considering it's one of my least
favorite episodes but two other
takeaways here are that one John shows
us again that he is a great warrior but
he makes bad decisions in the heat of
the battle just like in the Battle of
bastards he would have lost here he
would have died here of someone that
swooped in to save him in this case the
reanimated uncle Benjen and then also
the knight King had every opportunity to
kill him here just like he did in hard
home and decided against it or at least
he made it clear that that wasn't his
priority so that leads me to believe
it's probably not John and the revenge
aspect of it doesn't really make sense
with John either so what is the revenge
part about well that is the second thing
that I would say is the reason why it
has to be bran and that is his position
as the three-eyed Raven now the children
of the floors created the night King and
he has at least killed most of those
children that we've seen in the actual
series so far I don't think it's
definitive one way or another on the
show if there are still children living
but I don't think it's likely that the
night king is targeting someone or
something that hasn't been established
as a major character the nert at me is
holding out hope for more children order
of the Green Man I love faces type stuff
but I don't think that is directly
related to the Battle of Winterfell the
show's first three-eyed Raven has also
been taken out and that's how brand got
to where he is the important part here
is that the first three-eyed Raven was
considered the last greenseer by the
children and he was very important I
tend to lean to the idea at least in the
book that he was pulling the strings and
a lot of events that led up to where
we're at I made a video about the dire
wolves and how he might have played a
hand in that a couple years ago but
either way we saw that they protected
him with their magic and he was
searching for bran
now I don't want to go really deep into
the textual clues about this stuff
because I've made videos about that a
few years ago now and I don't want this
video to be super long keep in mind
though that the last three-eyed Raven
came to Brandon his dreams as a child he
most likely did this with other kids
several of them and there's at least
pretty good evidence that he probably
visited
you're on as a child in the books as
well and that you're on didn't make the
grade
you're on in the books is basically a
different character compared to the one
in the show though so it's not really
important that it was him what is
important is that brain is special very
special and very powerful you could
definitely say the brain is the most
powerful character in the story at least
in his skin changing or will say warding
because that's what they call it on the
show and his green singing abilities of
course he's crippled he can't walk so
it's not like he can defeat the knight
King in single combat but his powers
essentially make him the only person
that can help the side of the living
actually defeat the army of the dead in
my opinion this is where a story's
always been headed and it's led to a lot
of theories about bran that kind of go
way out into left field which I don't
subscribe to and I've made a video about
that in the past - about why I don't
think he's the night king and it
basically boils down to that I don't
think that this has been all leading up
to this sci-fi
time-travel twist it would be really a
big surprise and that's not to say it
can't happen it just doesn't seem like
that's where the series has been headed
so we know the children made the night
king we know that the children protected
the original three-eyed Raven and that
the three-eyed Raven came to bran the
children and the original three-eyed
Raven both basically sacrificed
themselves to make sure that brand lived
which also is a pretty big indicator of
how important he is so I don't really
think there's any chance that he has a
target that is someone other than brand
now we're another layer came into this
was like I said when I saw the run times
if everything's leading up to this
battle the war for the dawn and bran is
the key to actually defeating the night
king and that happens in Episode three
what's gonna happen after the fact you
know I cut I told this the real battle
because I think the real battle does
come down to bran and the night King but
then what is going to happen after the
fact now there's got to be a twist I've
said that in my last video you know
there has to be some sort of a twist
here and that's what I'm interested in
talking about
finding out what you guys think going
forward after this video does this mean
that they won't actually win at
Winterfell but if that's the case then
what happens did they beat the night
king back temporarily and he's still
there and there has to be another
showdown later on do they lose straight
up and then what like it's really kind
of hard to figure out where it goes from
there especially because you know we
know that the dead are a big threat so
what I was thinking about was related to
this idea but bran is powerful he is the
most powerful character in the realm of
magic at least right now obviously
there's other magical people that have
strong power but Brandes seems to be the
linchpin in this battle against him the
thing about this story is it's not
really about magic Magic's a part of it
but it's really not about magic it's
actually more about power when you think
about it you know zooms way out in the
beginning that was the big thing you
know we wondered what people would do to
get power keep power you know hold on to
the iron throne and so on this was
supposed to be the twist going back to
well you know actually none of that
matters because the dead are coming and
they're gonna wipe out everyone if they
don't pull together in this scenario now
where does the story go and is it really
still just about power because brands
power is very specific and it's not
necessarily useful beyond this situation
in a way I think it goes without saying
that the knight king will be defeated
and the White Walkers will be taken care
of I don't think that the knight King is
gonna sit on the throne at the end and
rule over Westeros are we missing a
piece of the puzzle here or does it just
take them that long to dispatch Cersei
and then we find out what happened after
once the dust has settled those are the
things that I'm thinking about when I'm
thinking about this upcoming season tell
me in the comments what you guys are
thinking about please give me a like on
the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe and set your notifications if
you haven't all
ready and feel free to ask any questions
about the stuff that I glossed over as
far as the textual evidence I'll try to
answer any questions that you have about
that in the comments as well thanks for
watching I appreciate it and I will talk
to you soon